hey everybody welcome back to LED live
today we are going to talk about a topic
that touches all of us social media are
you addicted find out on this episode of
LED live so guys who here is addicted to
social media and wants to fess up go on
oh man I think I might have to make
myself get off there sometimes
well I I know I'm telling you like
there's times where I have actually sat
down and and wasted hours away and just
went what whoa whoa what just happened
yeah I can literally went to my phone to
check an email yeah so today might be a
little hard for some of us to kind of
like talk about but before we get into
that Mikey introduce our guest here this
is my cousin Debra Elmo awesome well
thank you so much for coming on board
with us Debra it's it's a it's a joy to
have people come on and give us a little
fresh perspective and it's neat to kind
of hear everybody's experience so
welcome aboard and we'll get into this
topic of social media but nobody wants
to confess out nobody's addicted here I
probably was addicted to Facebook at one
point I absolutely hate it now what do
you think is the most watched or most
paid attention to social media site you
just give answer lady said watched
YouTube no sorry
well you can watch to Graham you can
actually watch these two no basically it
is Facebook it's facebook facebook is
still dominating as the number one most
like used app which is not very much of
a surprise because businesses use it and
you know so it's so on and so forth but
we use it yeah yeah you to YouTube's up
there so we're gonna get into a little
bit of this but first of all I want to
thank you guys for donating those of you
that have supported this ministry
man we owe all these shows to you guys
and we're able to put these out so thank
you if you haven't checked out our
patreon page and you would like to
figure out how to support our ministry
look at our patreon we got a lot of cool
perks there we've got a whole website
with documentaries that we produce on
various different subjects in fact
today's topic is really inspired by a
documentary we made called
selfie and this is all about social
media and how we'll cut to a trailer
right now so really what this report
shows Common Sense Media's founder says
it's like the digital transformation of
childhood and adolescent adolescence is
completely anyone who uses social media
might admit it can be hard to tear
yourself away now the former head of
Facebook says that's exactly what the
founders intended about seventy-seven
percent of parents think that it is more
difficult to raise teenagers today than
when they were growing up and so it's a
two-way street
the brain created social media and
social media shapes the brand alike that
releases dopamine which causes you to
spend more time with the device so these
are little electronic drug delivery
devices I know that's a crude way to put
it but that's what you're saying I think
in the back deep deep recesses of our
minds we kind of knew something bad
could happen but I think the way we
defined it was not like this if you use
social media or you have kids this is
really great information I mean you
really need to take a look at this
because this stuff is changing our
society we also have a Vimeo page where
you guys can watch digital versions of
all of our documentaries so check it out
of course we have a YouTube page but you
already know that you're already on
YouTube we also have t-shirts those of
you that love wearing t-shirts we sell
them and help support our ministry as
well so let's jump into this and let's
play a little game
are you addicted to social media let's
pick on snapchat anybody anybody never
throw snapchat we tried we tried
yeah we couldn't figure infant eye as
you try to do snapchat and and did you
know that snapchat is actually totally
on the decline it's so hard to use
they've lost millions of subscribers
because they literally say that older
people try to get onto it use it and
it's super confusing but here's here's
some way that if you play with this out
there you might want to you know take a
look at this if you're addicted to
snapchat if you have these posts and
they're more than a minute you know or
you keep posting minutes every single
day you might be addicted or if you're
playing with snapchat and you know what
all the filters actually do oh you know
what I mean
and you notice when the filters go away
so knowledge means addiction so eight a
minute Millie rarity if you yeah if you
actually yeah if you pay attention to
all of the little like filters and then
they take them out and they you know
give you new ones and stuff everyone's
wrong but you can actually add you know
a minute story so if you're adding a
minute story every single day you might
be addicted to snapchat right they don't
sound bad people yeah people over abuse
that little minute snapchat and they're
kind of constantly making stories all
day long so it only allows you to do one
minute a day you can't do two stories
that are a minute long and I think you
can I think you can yeah I don't I think
it limits you to a minute you you can
film for a minute and then use that a
film again so you can put as much as you
want but the videos are cut to yes so
you you have only a minute video but you
can do multiple videos yeah that's
that's I'm not a snapchat user so if if
you guys if you guys actually know what
the filters you were played with the
filters my wife has this on her phone
just for the filters we like to play
with our daughter my daughter gets a
little too into that thing yeah cuz
they're awesome and and you know you can
change your voice
even on some of them it's really really
kind of interesting but you might be
addicted if you are like Ellen here and
constantly find yourself playing with
these things for hours on end and making
silly faces and doing that
let's pick on Instagram though because
Instagram is one of the most popular
social media sites that's out there you
guys Instagram users yes yes
like avid Instagram users mm-hmm I don't
post much what I do scroll on my feet a
lot okay so so what have you ever have
you ever lit there scrolled through
everybody that's in your feed and then
set the phone down and then picked it
right back up and started scrolling
through it again never done all new
stuff yeah yeah this is something that
people do all the time because they have
literally chained themselves to like
float through the social media app and
it's just an involuntary action might be
addicted if you do that how about this
have you ever looked at what everybody
comments and then gone to that person
even though you don't know them and gone
and read they're calm with it
hey no no Instagram but yeah and all of
a sudden you're like floating down this
rabbit hole of people's comments and
looking at people's pages that really
you have no care for what you're just
like wonderful accept my request yeah
exactly
alright how about this for you avid
Instagram users out there have you ever
noticed that if you slide to one side on
the comments and you can actually see
when they commented and when they posted
you know there's all these special
features on there no no do you know that
do you know that so I would say if you
are actually reading through people's
comments and paying attention to when
they commented and trying to analyze why
they commented you might be addicted but
this is a feature that is built into it
how about Twitter you guys use Twitter I
didn't know you use Twitter I'm a
Twitter guy okay so like Twitter a lot
yeah do you tweet occasionally yeah
because I think most people that that
actually pay attention to Twitter I
think it's a small percentage of people
that actually tweet it's well about 40
percent of people on Twitter only follow
other people
don't tweet anything hmm it might be a
reposting and literally tweeting or
whatever but for me it's like a source
of news that's what I use it for and I
guess it suits my personality because
it's it's direct it's to the point
you're not getting a lot of fluff it's
just like there it is okay
so people that use Twitter for news and
stuff like this have you ever come
across people's tweets like this one
that says I just had waffles this
morning right no not really
people toys any of those ridiculous
things I mean our president tweets and
pretty ridiculous things right but they
tweet it like it's like this like
ongoing play-by-play of what they're
doing today and you know they they treat
it like a journal yeah you might be
addicted to Twitter if you are actually
tweeting that much
how about Facebook you never have you
ever you know seeing people that really
post every little thing that they do on
Facebook I don't do that like they
literally have a play-by-play commentary
as my life this is my life check in I'm
doing this is going I mean we all have
friends that are like that which is
funny and it's kind of a funny little
meme you guys ever use the poke feature
this will have them no yeah I haven't
but to me it's the most annoying thing
isn't it creepy it's still creepy like
somebody poked weed like they're what
they're watching I mean you know when
you get on Facebook and all of a sudden
it's like ding ding ding ding all these
people start messaging you like as if
are you just waiting around hey I think
I think now the poke has kind of been
replaced with the little hand wave in
the messenger though because I've gotten
that before and I'm like ok I know this
person I haven't talked to in a while
and the sudden I got a hand and I've
asked him did you send me that they're
like no I guess Facebook like just
randomly thrown out hand waves to start
conversation I mean we'll kind of get
into that a little bit but yeah it's
very interesting I mean have you ever
noticed on Facebook as well they give
you the little read like somebody reads
it yeah the messenger do you like that
feature like knowing whether they've
read your ganna do you like that feature
do you ever check it and be like I know
I just sent him a message of a they read
it yeah
yeah don't even tell you to know that
they got it they wrote it yeah but then
you have a lot of people say they left
me on read you know so that's something
like yeah you know how like especially
iOS devices you know how it gives you a
little notification at the top right
do you ever purposely not click into it
because yes didn't know yes you actually
read it and it lets you read it I've
done that as well just like the preview
no oh yeah you just kind of just read it
real quick and this all went away and I
don't want to look at it because they'll
know that I looked at it you may like
the little drop-down notification yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've done that that's
funny all right how about youtube let's
pick on YouTube because I love YouTube
YouTube is my favorite how about this
mean going on to YouTube to watch a five
minute music video five hours later
you're watching a tutorial on how to
talk to giraffe anybody guilty of that
yeah that's a little like a
recommendation bar anything pops up
there I have literally gone there to
learn how to do something and I'll find
out like this is how they make jelly
beans at how things are made because I
thought if we're gonna use social media
let's use it for cool reasons things we
can actually go and visually see
happening and so it started off with
like how balloons are made it was very
interesting but the toilet is kind of
captivate there are whole videos that
show you these machines that just pump
out stuff and it's like the way that it
like moves around and you're just like
alright how about this one homework and
work can wait but youtube can write
you're gonna set aside your work you're
gonna watch YouTube before because that
particular thing is coming on but I
think it's funny is like you know we do
a lot of live shows or premieres where
we do have people that are waiting to
watch that and some people do comment
I'm at work you know and I'm waiting to
watch this so so that was kind of funny
alright how about this one
you have friends because
anybody know any of this no I think yeah
communicates a lot of people got people
all over the world all right how about
this one a lot of people know you a lot
of people in the comments-section know
you and have and you've made top comment
more than once oh boo boo yeah I've
become top fan of a couple of pages yeah
I guess that means you comment a lot I
don't know what I mean yeah can you
think of our commenters like do we know
specific ones that comment no a
shout-out brother thank you so I'm gonna
show you guys a couple of videos that
there are some very prominent people
that have come out and started to talk
about this whole addiction matter and
social media and when you know and we
started in the city it's a little
alarming because these are tools that we
use all the time so what what can we
really do to safeguard ourselves so that
we're not falling into this pit of this
little rat race that they basically have
us all running on so check out some of
these videos social media has become
part of our nature we post we share we
like we follow we unfollow we subscribe
but how is social media affecting us a
small study of 20 college students found
a correlation between students who
demonstrated higher levels of Facebook
addiction and activity in the amygdala
striatal system while they interacted
with Facebook signals this activation
was the same seen in those with
substance addiction in a 2016 UCLA study
teams were split into two groups one was
shown a photo with the high number of
likes and the other group was shown the
same photo but with fewer likes those
who viewed the photo with more likes
were more likely to like the photo
themselves in the group who saw the
photo it's fewer likes again it was the
same picture this experiment found
activity in multiple parts of the brain
when teens saw photos they took receive
a lot of likes in particular the study
found significant activity in part of
the brain's reward circuitry known as
the nucleus accumbens dopamine is
released in the brain up
positive social stimuli such as likes
and positive comments on social media
that photos she just posted she got a
bunch of likes releasing dopamine into
her brain and causing a feeling of
satisfaction
[Music]
psychologist BF Skinner found that mice
would respond to certain stimuli they
knew resulted in our award more often
when the reward came at variable times
this theory can also be applied to
social media and the times we check it
looking for a reward in terms of a like
comment or message we habitually check
our accounts but we are not always
rewarded maybe this photo didn't get the
amount of life's you wanted so you will
try again and again and again looking
for that reward but wait something else
have you ever felt your phone vibrate
when it really didn't according to
robert rosenberger of the Georgia
Institute of Technology we become so
connected to our phones that they've
sort of become part of our bodies
anytime something stimulates or triggers
sensation in an area where you keep your
phone you might believe it's your phone
this is called phantom vibration
syndrome
studies show that nearly 90% of people
report experiencing these phantom
vibrations 90% so so what's really going
on here what's really going on in social
media is is it's really tapping into the
chemistry of our brains I mean like they
said you know we have all these devices
that have these built in basically like
buttons and you know people can comment
and you know all of that is feeding into
our psychology and our desire as humans
to be liked and validated and then we
get this little rush of dopamine that's
like ah wow yay somebody liked my video
or somebody liked my post and that
causes you to come back in and literally
post more anything interesting about
this video that jumped out at you I
thought it was interesting that the the
people like the ones that are already
liked it's that sheep herd like
mentality like I like it because other
people like it and I think that's what
makes things go viral you know you see
some of the most ridiculous things
you've IRA like why is this even viral
doesn't it make sense
well because somehow it got a thousand
likes and that just made other people
keep sharing it oh it must be funny
because every
he's putting a laughing face on it right
yeah I think it's the same with
subscribers there are channels that have
millions of subscribers but wretch my
head gone how does this person have a
following you brought up you brought up
the other day the people that just eat
food or something like that and people
watch them just eat food yes tomorrow
and and I remember just watching a
couple of videos and then it was crazy
as I thought it was so insane but then I
just wanted to watch it yeah have you
ever seen these I have had one I was
like what it was socially like soothing
or there I was like isn't that annoying
near someone cranking up there's some
people they have like this tingling
sensation in their neck or something
supposed to sue them but it's not for
everyone
yeah it's just the most heartless of
that fact they still get millions of
views millions of views and like we put
all this editing effort in try to make
these videos meet and it's like we got a
couple mm some artists product people
who are really drawn to and then there's
just the weird factor that gets the
likes to you yeah so all of it really is
pushing the chemistry in our brain
that's really what all of this stuff is
really doing so there's a lot of people
that have come out and and and seen you
know there's there's some real tangible
issues that are starting to arise with
with constantly running around and like
like like the little rats and pushing
the button with the lever or the little
hit you know and it's like what is this
actually doing to us so check this out
what you're doing with an addictive
generation this is a big time bomb
ticking this is no accident
indeed it is by design I mean seriously
it was my mistake I mean I think we can
all feel it to try to make these
products as addictive as a spike in
dopamine
we now know that many of the major
social media companies hire individuals
called attention engineers who borrow
principals from Las Vegas casino
gambling among other places to try to
make these products as addictive as
possible that is the desired use case
with these products is that you use it
in an addictive fashion because that
maximizes the profit that can be
extracted from your attention and data
it literally is a point now
where I think we have created tools that
are ripping apart the social fabric of
how society works that is truly where we
are the way the technologists Garan
lunaire puts it is that these companies
offer you shiny treats in exchange for
minutes of your attention and bytes of
your personal data which can then be
packaged up and sold what happened is
that the attention economy in this race
for attention got more and more
competitive and the more competitive it
got to get people's attention on its a
news website the more they need to add
these design principles these more
manipulative design tactics as ways of
holding on to your attention you don't
realize it but you are being programmed
social media tools are designed to be
addictive the actual design desired use
case of these tools is that you fragment
your attention as much as possible
throughout your waking hours that's how
these tools are designed to use well we
have a growing amount of research which
tells us that if you spend large
portions of your day in a state of
fragmented attention so large portions
of your day we are constantly breaking
up your attention take a quick blanch to
just check them just quickly look at
Instagram that this can permanently
reduce your capacity for concentration I
am especially worried about this when we
look at the younger generation coming up
which is the most saturated this
technology and it's very addictive
because if you pull on the slot machine
arm enough you will win
and you never know which poll will
reward you so that's quite a few voices
that are literally saying listen there's
there's some real issues with living our
lives constantly addicted to this push
of dopamine inside of our bodies and
brains
what do you guys think about that it's
more than just attention spans affected
in fact we know from research that it's
a 10 to 20 percent reduction in the
brain in areas of speech memory motor
control sensory and other information so
you know it really makes you question do
I want to sacrifice 10 to 20% of my
brain capacity in those areas and you
know is it a wonder that we have trouble
communicating
you know if we're and in trouble with
anger and trouble with all these other
things you know we're experience every
reduction if we're locked in
yes alright and it seems like it's
affecting all areas of life especially
in my generation they made the point
that okay this is the generation that's
just steeped in this stuff and look look
what's happening you know less people
are going to school communication is is
really bad and just people can't or
don't want to hold down a job they'd
rather travel around because they want
that stimulation all the time it's it's
evident yeah for sure yeah you're
running around looking at the most
exciting parts of life and you know you
live with this view of constantly paying
attention to everybody else's exciting
moments and you know that that I'm sure
is contributing to the depression that a
lot of these teens are having it's like
you you you you you look at your life
and you go mine's slower and it's not
that exciting and I don't have that many
friends and I didn't get invited to that
party all of those things are are really
I think are plaguing this up-and-coming
generation so Mikey you have kids Keefe
you have kids
kindiy you do not Deb really got kids
you got kids what do we do I have kids
in this situation because my kids are
growing up playing with our devices you
know
they already know how to work the iPhone
better than me sometimes and you know
luckily I haven't crossed that bridge
yet where they have asked me for their
own phone which i think is an absolute
no for a while but they will eventually
have to have this tool I mean that's
just part of life right it's terrifying
unless we all go back and flip phones I
was looking at him online I don't know
how long they're gonna be supported
though you know uh-huh
plus I gotta have the GPS yeah well I
had a flip phone for many years even up
until about a year ago and I had a
smartphone that I bought for 30 bucks
off of the marketplace and you can use
it for Wi-Fi or whatever and and even
when you don't have a connection you can
use the GPS on yeah so that was helpful
I would like to speak to that though and
say that I have recently read an article
and I find this very telling that a lot
of the software manufacturers are in
Silicon Valley and you can go and look
at articles to verify what I'm saying
you would think that they would have the
the cutting-edge technology in their
schools they don't make em talk words
and they have chalk and they hardly use
technology the makers of this stuff Bill
Gates and the guy who made snapchat they
don't allow their kids on social media
hardly at all so when you're looking at
people who are manufacturing this for
other people but they're protecting
their own kids I think that tells the
entire user California's Waldorf schools
yeah the way that they do that is they
they say no technology in the classroom
before eight or through eighth grade
once they get into high school
technology is permitted Wow but before
that time no they axons lately yeah my
mom was on that bandwagon I didn't get a
facebook I wasn't allowed to have a
Facebook till I was 16 on my 16th
birthday she allowed me to log in and I
thought it would really like impact my
school life my social life but it really
didn't I found out who my true friends
were if something was popular in line
they would pull up their account show me
would talk about it but then we'd move
on it was never a big deal that I wasn't
on social media and I still have those
friends today so I didn't really a PAC
impact me the way I thought it would and
once you got on social media you
probably didn't look back at the
experience of
like oh man I miss town so much yeah
just kind of move on rightly so I
believe that there is a responsibility
at the age to that you get a little
older you know how to to treat it handle
it for you know what I mean and instead
there's a lot of trouble you can get
into which we do cover in this we talked
a little bit about some experiences of
people targeting young kids on Facebook
and really getting into trouble zone so
not only just you know it's addictive
and and it's gonna mess with your life
like that but there's some very real
predators online that can do a lot of
damage just communicating with your kids
so I think it's a really smart idea and
there's literally should be an age limit
on that technology in you know well
there's there's in some ways they're
supposed to be like it's per Facebook I
think they're supposed to be an age
limit that you sign up but if you lie
about your birthday you're gonna get on
and it doesn't know the difference
because it's not there with a
representative checking you right so
right now it's very real that we're
dealing with addiction and so there's
there's some some some guys that are
really starting to comment about like
you know what are we what are we gonna
start to do about this what what can we
do about this listen to this simon Sinek
famously says if you know you wake up in
the morning and you're you know checking
your phone before you're saying hello to
your spouse that's an addictive behavior
and it's dopamine that is driving that
addiction so what happens with social
media is Robert Sapolsky you did the
foundational research on this and
Stanford calls it the magic of maybe
when you look at your phone and maybe
there's a text there and maybe there's
not and you don't know when it shows up
that high you get that's dopamine it's
the magic of maybe maybe it'll be there
maybe it won't want it shows up you get
a 400% spike in dopamine that is roughly
the same amount of dopamine as you're
getting from cocaine it's slightly less
than an extremely addictive drug like
cocaine and that's what's happening and
it's interesting because if you think
about things like things that you know
routinely produced a lot of dopamine
alcohol for example there's a drinking
age right we have a drinking alcohol
releases a whole lot of dopamine it
makes you feel really really
we say okay you can have that but you
gotta wait you've got to be 21 years old
we don't do that with online pornography
we might want to do with online
pornography we don't do that with social
media we're you know essentially putting
highly addictive drugs into the hands of
kids before they have any natural
defenses against them and what you're
seeing with Internet addiction with
social media addiction with porn
addiction it's the same thing over and
over it's people trying to change their
state of consciousness with a device
trying to get at the underlying neural
chemical chemistry and it's very very
dated
so you know as parents you you have to
realize and recognize that these devices
were designed to basically hold your
attention release that dopamine and like
you said I mean isn't that crazy a 400%
spike in dopamine is like doing cocaine
I mean we wouldn't let kids or anybody
it's illegal to do cocaine but here it
is we are we are handing them these
devices and and getting them roped in
and that's why I think you know parents
just need to be judicious about this and
and not allow those young kids to to
have their own social media accounts
until their till they're older and talk
with them about it you know don't just
hand the device and-and-and I let them
have free rein
[Music]
well there's a really common
misconception that technology is neutral
and it's up to us to just choose how to
use it and so we're sitting there and
we're scrolling and we find ourselves in
this kind of wormhole and then we say oh
man like I should really have more
self-control and that's partially true
but what we forget when we talk about it
that way is that there's a thousand
engineers and the other side of the
screen
whose job it was was to get my finger to
do that the next time and there's this
whole playbook of techniques that they
use to get us to keep using the software
more so was design always this
manipulative you know it wasn't always
this way
in fact back in the 1970s in the early
80s at Xerox PARC when Steve Jobs first
went over and saw the graphical user
interface the way people talked about
computers and what computers were
supposed to be was a bicycle for our
minds that here we are you take a human
being and they have a certain set of
capacities and capabilities and then you
give them a bicycle and they can go to
all these new distances they're
empowered to go to these brand new
places and to do these new things to
have these new capacities and that's
always been the philosophy of people who
make technologies how do we create
bicycles for our minds to do and empower
us to feel and access more now when the
first iPhone was introduced it was also
the philosophy of these technology how
do we empower people to do something
more and what and in those days it
wasn't manipulative because there is no
competition for attention Photoshop
wasn't trying to maximize how much
attention it took from you it didn't
measure its success that way and the
internet overall had been in the very
beginning not designed to maximize
attention it was just of putting things
up there putting things out there
creating these message boards it wasn't
designed with this whole persuasive
psychology that emerged later what
happened is that the attention economy
in this race for attention got more and
more competitive and the more
competitive it got to get people's
attention on its a news website the more
they need to add these design principles
these more manipulative design tactics
as ways of holding on to your attention
and so YouTube goes from being a more
neutral honest tool of just hears of
video - oh do you want to see these
other videos and oh do you want to
autoplay the next video and oh do you
want to you know you know here's some
notifications these products start to
look and feel more like media that's
about maximizing consumption and less
like bicycles for our minds and I think
that's such a subtle and important thing
to recognize is that more and more of
technology's really not on our team to
help us spend our time the way we want
to it's more on the team of maximizing
how much time we spend on the screen
well you know what I find especially
irritating about that you have all these
services anymore that are there doing
this and then they're also charging
subscriptions yeah you know so it's like
they get you hooked and then it's like
now we need to draw up your bank account
a little bit too it's like as if you're
not making enough money off my
information and my time already through
advertisements now you're even gonna
charge me for it so true you know III
think it's very interesting how he kind
of set it up - is it wasn't a malicious
intent in the beginning and just the
nature of the beast it's like
everybody's kind of morphed into this
like how can we consume as much of your
time as humanly possible and and that is
really like where the psychology that's
being pumped into this I mean they're
these you guys think every one of these
little apps there's people in boardrooms
very intelligent people that have
literally designed these things to be
like you know how can we literally prove
that that people are using this thing
like 810 hours out of the day you know I
appreciate that there's still a back
door to get back to the original intent
and that's just to be aware and to be
intentional so there is a toggle on
YouTube to stop autoplay so it doesn't
go to the next video you know so being
aware of those things and how to help
yourself and not become addicted if you
put those in place then you can use
these platforms for their original
intent which is to get information and
you know YouTube actually has a a thing
that shows you how many hours you spent
on it yeah I know informants - well I
was terrified when I went in there and I
saw like it was
like 48 hours or something but it's
because it was logged in a little light
we're all looking at videos at the same
time this isn't even humanly possible
that's all we do we just watch YouTube
videos non-stop but yeah the first time
I saying like it measures your hours so
that you can look and be like oh I got
here a little way too long yeah I know
you can put like is it like a timer on
your phone so once you open up the
Facebook app it gives you like five
minutes and then actually shuts down the
app so you can't keep scrolling that's
pretty cool yeah you bring up a really
good point I mean like he said the
misnomer in the beginning is really just
like well you just need to stop yeah but
like any addiction you need to know that
you you are aware of there's this
potential I mean if you're if you're not
even aware that there's an addiction out
there you can't solve the problem so you
have to first say okay these things are
designed this way now what do I do with
this and how do I begin to safeguard
against this like in my house you know
we take steps to we don't let our
children play with technology in their
rooms and so if they want to look at
something on the computer or they want
to play with the phone it's literally in
my view you cannot go to your room and
just check out you know what I mean like
to me that that is is asking for trouble
down the road
yeah and so you know there's there's
ways that you can begin to then you know
build some parameters around that and
teach how to basically navigate in an
addictive world I don't know it's it's
so much similar at least it we're trying
to make it work it doesn't always happen
but I make the kids ask yeah and with
along with you asked its what are you
doing with it you know so we know like
what your intent is and then you know we
check up on them what are you doing like
if I see my son with something I'm
asking him what are you doing you know
how long is that gonna take you that
kind of things but it's not just oh I
have free rein all the time whatever
whenever and I also got a new router at
my house my brother gave me a router he
was getting rid of really liked it it
has a feature where I can take the
devices I think it uses the MAC address
of the device and you add it to a list
that says this device can access the
Internet
between these hours mm-hmm so like he
has his own little iPad you know that's
he's supposed to ask us before you use
it but you know at 8 o'clock at night
that thing is it can't access the
Internet sorry buddy you're out of luck
and you know not until like 9:00 in the
morning or something something like that
so you just shut down the hours which I
really love that feature I think that's
awesome
my mom made me a log in on our desktop
at home when I was I think it was in
middle school and I had two hours a day
so and that's everything like if to do
my homework do whatever social things I
won't watch videos you have two hours so
that's also time management you know
what are you gonna put first what's your
already because after that two hours
sorry Kathy yeah but it's good advice
for us adults as well like we need to
learn how to be able to shut off the
technology set it down engage with the
family you know otherwise you know you
guys might know this as well like you
know you start answering emails you
start communicating with people and you
got to do this back and forth thing and
her kids are like hey dad come on play
with me and I'll get I'll get to that
and then you don't and then you go to
bed and you go hey that that little I
think it's like they safe 15 minutes a
days all the male has with his kid and
it's like 45 minutes for a female like
like we're talking quality time and so
those little times are very precious to
your your upbringing and if we're just
checked out watching videos and
responding on social media then we lose
out on those little precious moments
yeah
there's a lot of groups medical groups
that are recommending that when you do
do things in media you know you should
do them with your child yeah you know
you know I'm just free reign access
whatever you want whenever you want in
other words we do this together
it's also one of the recommendations in
a book I think I've recommended this
before on the show it's called and the
tech wise family by Andy Crouch he has a
list in there the ten tech wise
commitments so it'd be a good book to
check out cool so listen to this study
that came out it was very interesting in
in just the use
of social media and why it's actually
bad for our mental health because this
is also something that I think when you
understand how these tools work and you
understand sort of the pitfalls and the
dangers of them hopefully that will help
you avoid them a little bit but they did
a study this came out in Forbes magazine
just to really but to kind of talk a
little bit about the this social media
and why is it contributing to like
depression and things like that right
York University in Canada found that
young women who were asked to interact
with a post of someone that they
perceived more attractive felt worse
about themselves afterwards so what
happened here is these two
these women were actually asked you can
look at a post of someone that you think
is more attractive than you or you can
look at a post of someone that's like a
family friend or somebody that's gonna
give you form fuzzy feelings because you
know them and the people that chose to
look at someone that was more attractive
and always felt more depressed
afterwards I mean that's not just social
media I mean you go to the store there's
a magazine you do the same thing
yes but what is that feeling bad
actually going to do to you listen to
this the results that were showed these
young women who felt more dissatisfied
with their bodies says the study author
Jennifer Mills in a statement they felt
worse about their own appearance after
looking at social media pages of someone
that they perceived to be more
attractive than them even if they felt
bad about themselves before they came
into the study on average they still
felt worse after completing the task I'm
wondering if that's a symptom of you
know some a root cause because I if I
look at a post like that I'm like
motivated like okay where can I improve
myself and that's not the case for
everyone so is it a thinking like why
why are they feeling this way when they
interact with those posts are there
you're hitting you're hitting the nail
actually kind of on the head of why
they're getting to this okay when you
actually see somebody and you get a
negative feeling like that you're all of
sudden gonna look at other people like
let's just say it's in the area of
fashion you see somebody who's very
fashionable they look great then all of
a sudden you're more likely to go to the
internet and look at other things like
where can I buy a shirt like this or
where can I do so that negative feeling
is actually driving people to post
cat stare at more it and and it's
designed actually to put that up front
and center with everybody I mean you
know it's like magazines not everybody
looks like that right you you don't you
don't that's not a real picture of how
life really is but what does that do
that makes women want to you know try
strive harder go to back to shop more
you know all those things is drive drive
drive that traffic and so in a social
media world it does this very similar
thing here's the bottom line says the
honest at ease a thermal issah hunt in a
statement using less social media than
you normally would leads to a
significant decrease in both depression
and loneliness these effects are
particularly pronounced in folks who
were more depressed when they came into
the study so if you step if you are
prone to depression one thing that is
going to absolutely like not help you is
diving more into social media but but
the reality of the situation is that's
what people do when you're depressed
what do you do you pull the phone you
start going into it more and so it's
like this like cycle that just you feel
worse then you post more you look at
more you get involved in it more I was
just gonna say I can completely speak to
that because I went through a season
years ago where I was very isolating I
have a special-needs child and so my
social life was was very limited because
of that and I discovered social media
well I became completely addicted to
both MySpace and Facebook and I was to
the point where if you stopped at a red
light you're on your phone to check you
know before you you get up in the middle
and I and your honor and it fragments
your mind it's like you're living in
reality with your family and your kids
and all that but your mind is constantly
running on this comment someone said and
how they're gonna react to this things
and all that and I felt fragmented I
felt like I wasn't fully satisfied with
either world and it was an absolute
addiction and for me I had to completely
shut down my social media and it's like
an alcohol
you know some people can can drink a
beer and be fine but for someone who
knows that that's been a struggle for
them it's like freedom is just I don't
know you know but it does you know I
reached out to that because I was kind
of dealing with some depression and
stuff and it actually does it takes you
deeper into that because the real thing
you need is the redemptive love and it's
it's a false offering of that and that
is actually taking you deeper into
something that you're dealing with hmm
Wow
you know we touched on this in our
documentary a little bit that the the
heavy social media use actually makes
you more internally focused on yourself
especially if you're an avid post or
whatever you're constantly looking at
your yourself and comparing yourself to
other people and that that that will in
turn or that will lead to depression
because when you're so self-absorbed and
so self focused that that's kind of the
end result of that and and I've talked
to psychologists before one of the best
ways to get somebody out of a depressed
state is actually to take them to like a
food bank and have them go serve other
people the more that you can get them
away from being focused on yourself the
better off they are the more that you
dive into this Oh me and it's all about
me and you can't see anything else but
yourself
then the depression just kind of
perpetuates you're actually involved in
a ministry like that you brought up
community my thing is when a person is
depressed like their their whole
thinking is warped so is it really for
them to reach out or for the people
around them to reach out to them me
using social media it may not affect me
in the same way as someone else but I
may be affecting the people around me
with not recognizing if someone around
me is depressed and maybe I should put
my phone down and help them out to be
that alt alternate thing for them to do
so maybe they're using social media
because they don't have people around
them so I can be that person I could be
that friend to reach out to them so
there is research that suggests if you
have a significant medical condition
where you cannot go out and socialize
normally like you're just completely
isolated that that is an instance where
social media can
beneficial because it allows you to have
a sense of community whereas you would
have none
normally hmm the other thing that we
know from scientific research is that
people who use social media to augment
their existing relationships or not so
in other words not you know comparing
yourself to a woman that you don't know
or whatever that those are not
considered to be harmful as far as they
can tell when you start to use it
outside of your normal relationships
that's when you start to get yourself in
trouble and you get depressed and you
get in this comparative state and you
start to see signs of decline in trouble
hmm good point good point so there's a
little bit of psychology that that's
gonna be touched on here in this next
video clip that I want to show you and
he he's kind of describing how it works
and why people are are so drawn to
posting we know that exposure to social
media is more precisely exposure to
strain time but not all strain time but
exposure to screen time and in social
media we know that it tends to encourage
depression anxiety suicide and so on
some numbers anxiety anxiety among teens
increased by 20% since 2007
17% of all teens with anxiety are today
with severe anxiety life-threatening
anxiety 17% compared to 3 about 10 years
ago we know that screen time decreases
happiness decreases life satisfaction
everything I'm mentioning is a study
attached to it or studies attached to it
so it decreases happiness likes
instruction and decreases self-esteem we
know that we know that it increases
enhances anxiety and depression the
Royal Society of public health published
a study in June this year June 2018
which found out that 63 63 percent of
all Instagram users are unhappy now we
don't know whether unhappy people
gravitate to Instagram where the
Instagram made them unhappy
yeah but since we have similar
statistics or other social media
it would stand to reason that it's the
platform that made them unhappy not the
other way we know that anxiety and
depression among the young as a young
between 15 and 24 increased by 70% over
the last 30 years that's a huge it's
rich double simply double and we know
that since 2010
teen suicide climbed by 31% so teen
suicide is rampant and today it is the
first time in human history that the
leading cause of death among teens up to
the age of 24 it's suicide
not any disease or not even accidents
used to be accidents today suicide
that's a leading cause of death and this
is intimately connected to social media
I wish they were more specific there had
to have been a common link in all those
people's lives who committed suicide or
a depressed other than social media I
think that it's not necessarily it's so
hard to put your finger exactly on this
is the culprit and and you know this is
this is what's causing this because
society is changing the way that we are
interacting is changing and all of those
things together I believe are
contributing with with with this whole
depression thing with teens I mean like
you said the studies that they found was
just Instagram alone 60 percent of
people that tinker with Instagram have a
higher state of depression that's high
yeah I think some of this goes back to
somebody referenced a video by simon
Sinek which i recommend to a lot of
people and when he talks about it he
says that when you are a teenager you
are you start making friendships with
you know your peers right and he
describes it as this experience that's
very frustrating for your parents you
know but but necessary for the
development of the teen so that I can
you know start to incorporate themselves
into the larger world
and he makes a comparison that like
alcohol most people that are alcoholics
they find alcohol when they're teenagers
and so when they start to experience
stress they turned to the bottle they
don't turn to their peers and so I he
shows that it's the same thing with
devices and technology and social media
so you're having the same group of kids
they have Ana dopamine you know
producing substances devices all around
them and instead of turning to friends
they turn to those and it's just like
the experience with the alcoholic so
there's they're experiencing stress you
know career stress financial stress you
know other other other forms of stress
and so when you immerse them then in all
these devices and those devices in turn
create more depression so I think you're
just watching this whole thing feed
itself right so I mean that's that's one
of the best explanations at least and
I've ever heard is you know the stress
already exists so how are you coping
with it are you going to your friends
and dealing with stress or are you going
to the dopamine producing device and
dealing with stress and if you're doing
that it only makes you more depressed
it's hard to can constantly beat up on
social media because you know we use
social media I mean you're watching this
on social media right now I mean there's
there's very real people that use these
tools and use them very positively you
know we've been able to share messages
around the world whether it be on
Facebook or there be on YouTube there's
a lot of like positive things with it
but listen to how these these
psychologists the designers the people
that are making this thing them they're
all recognizing this it's like we've
created this monster and and it's this
you know white elephant in the room
because everybody's using it but we
don't know quite what to do with it at
this point how do we begin to build
these safeguards into it think about
this 60% of people that are more
depressed because they tinker with with
Instagram or 60% of them will
a higher state of depression if we if I
had a drug right now that I was to give
to you and say you know what in a couple
of weeks you're gonna lose weight and
you're going to lose it incredibly fast
but the side effect is 60% of these
people are literally gonna be super
depressed and commit suicide the FDA
would make that drug illegal tomorrow
like you wouldn't even get to this point
and so here is this thing that's
producing this drug inside of us this
dopamine rush literally addicting
everybody to it but society is how hard
time dealing with this right now here's
where the rubber meets the road is it's
where ethics meets finance so all these
companies that are producing this stuff
they know it they know everybody's
addicted and they want people to use
their platforms because that means more
for their bottom line it's not in their
best interest to implement ethics for
their customers even though it may be
killing them right okay so everything to
you I had read where they were actually
exploiting the depression because the
people who are behind the scenes making
these apps and stuff they can recognize
behaviors and posts and even I want to
think it was Instagram I don't want to
say that if it was the wrong platform
but they actually exploited that by
detecting when someone was depressed and
deliberately putting images in front of
them that further depression and then
how long how it would affect that person
over time I mean it's like experimenting
with human nature for the sake of
marketing or how they you know benefit
on the the other end of the spectrum but
it goes back to your you know your rats
and the cage we're the rats are being
experimented with and sometimes we've
been paying money to be experimenting on
[Laughter]
this is gonna sound so messed up but
it's true I remember when we were doing
the Joker episode I asked the question
should that movie have been banned
because of how it affected the minority
should it have been banned for the
majority and shutting down social media
platforms because of what's happening to
a percentage of young people nowadays I
mean that's cutting off information
that's cutting off freedom of speech to
the larger population to the world so
it's like you've created this elephant
but to just destroy it because of the
Fix it'll have them in some ways yes in
some ways no because if you still have
public broadcasting and news you still
have a source of information
you just have cut off somebody's
preferred method it's not necessary for
them to receive the information in that
way and I don't think the answer to is
just cutting it off I think that we need
to be able to discuss some very real
things with what we do about this
should there be age limits on it should
there be you know there should be more
information put in the mainstream I mean
our news companies should be
broadcasting hey be careful these things
are like this or maybe there should be
some ethics with with businesses that
use those psychological tactics to try
and keep you on there as long as
possible maybe there needs to be some
sort of like you know taper ease down of
that that machine that they're allowed
that free rein with our minds what yeah
it's weird because you look at it's like
cocaine nope we're never gonna make it
legal it's illegal it's unethical we
fight wars isn't that yeah it doesn't
matter if you got free speech or
whatever cocaine is outlawed the
cigarettes we'll just put a warning on
there it's legal yeah maybe it just
needs to have like Facebook just always
pops up a warning like you've been on
here a long time they're like that's the
only thing I can think the bottom line
middle we're still dealing with freedom
of choice and and free will and and like
I like I like I always kind of come to
this thing I don't know if just
controlling what people do is the answer
I think giving information letting
people have their own choice you can
choose I mean the reason why we wanted
to do a show like this was really to
just give the tools to to parents to
people that are that are struggling with
this know how this stuff works
know that these engineers and these
psychologists are talking about this and
saying hey look we designed this thing
to be like this what can we do from here
but as Christians we need to be
especially careful because what we're
seeing happen is it's becoming harder
and harder to have one of the fruit of
the Spirit which is self-control
you know temperance and here we are
putting all these roadblocks in front of
us and other people putting roadblocks
in front of us to be able to exercise
self-control good point and that's not a
good place to be it's a good point well
here's some of the stresses with the
especially Instagram social media social
media typically is someone's highlight
reel you know they're only gonna show
you their best parts life isn't really
like that like like we don't see the
middle parts the struggles the tears
that you know often we see it adjust so
hey we're having fun and this is great
and so when you're looking at somebody
else's experience or life in that way
you then turn to internalize that and go
man I don't live in that kind of a house
I don't have those kind of clothes I
don't have those kind of friends and
that in turn can be a source of
depression social media is not your
currency for your self-worth that's do
you know what I mean by that meaning
like I am NOT validated because I posted
something and 2,000 people liked what I
posted that bet says nothing about my
self-worth at all but in today's world
that's literally how people are viewing
their self-worth I mean there's there's
there's people like famous youtubers
that have literally like gone and wanted
to commit suicide literally because
people stopped liking them or or they
did something really not that that
nobody liked and and then that just
ruined their life this makes me think of
the the Chinese the social credit score
like this could become a reality it's
pretty scary to think about the things
that you do could affect your life in
society but you can't get you can't ride
this public transportation because you
said something negative about the
government the only realized when he
tried to buy a train ticket and was told
he was banned from traveling or there's
even public shaming and stuff I'm sure
you've seen that yep
Bible tells us in first Corinthians 6:20
that we were bought with a price that's
right you know it's Christ death which
which causes our life to have any kind
of value at all
not what we find out in the world
infinite value to God because he was
willing to give heavens best his own son
and I just think about that in my own
experience would I give my son to die so
that everyone else would live you know
what I mean it's like we would
appreciate it
yeah it's like if you kind of just
consider that mind of god it just makes
you go wow I want to serve that kind of
God yeah while we were yet still sinners
not a bunch of people who love you
people who hate you and you're gonna
give your son for him that's right
mind-blowing dude another issue is the
fear of missing out don't look at what
everybody else is doing out there and
you know compare your slower paced life
or that you don't have the money to go
on a vacation like everybody else or
you're not asked to go to this party or
that hang out with those friends that is
a very real fear that especially
teenagers are experiencing also cyber
bullying I don't know if you guys have
ever experienced this I think social
media kind of came out when I was more
of an adult so I'm not really
necessarily one that has first-hand
experience of being bogan anybody oh
yeah
you've been bullied pip I mean a lot of
people say I don't know if you want to
call it bullying but you know yeah I get
into a lot of debates and when you bring
up a lot of good points the person just
resorts to name-calling or whatever so
yeah yeah I have thick skin I know that
that the to me it's just more fat more
credit in my favor you know when they
start doing that thing that's right well
I I have appreciated your loving
approach with people and I think we all
need to do that with with people who
like really experience this my niece
experienced this cyber bullying she had
gone to a new school and kids that were
coming to the school like literally were
were posting terrible things about her
and it made her literally not want to go
to the school I mean she would come on
crying so this is a very real experience
with kids and parents we need to be
aware of this we need to talk about this
with our kids we need to not allow this
to happen because you could be
destroying somebody's life so this is
this is something that I think is is
very real listen to what this
psychologist keeps kind of
hammering away here well I mentioned
before that social media is is a
conditioning tool not an addictive tool
but a conditioning tool and that it uses
a relative positioning but what are the
emotions that are attached to relative
positioning with the first one is envy
of course so social media are
constructed around envy pathological
Envy they are purveyors of pathological
Envy in amplifiers of pathological
ending and they quantify via various
ranking algorithms they quantify envy
with likes with retweets with so they
quantify envy and then they leverage
envy to to motivate you in other words
they use Envy to cause you to adopt some
course of action so they weaponize Envy
well if these social media devices are
cultivating envy what does that mean for
us Christians what is that what is that
really like doing to us wiring
reprogramming us especially when you're
supposed to be truthful and honest and
now you mean truthful and honest with
your posts I think it means we're less
connected in the way that we're supposed
to be appreciate ya right Envy I think
is one of the ways that the devil can
kind of just get in the door there and
and really start to to to make us take
our eyes off of Jesus and to really
place it on others things materialism I
think a lot of that stuff comes out of
out of envy listen the way he goes on to
sample we see this all social media
encourage aggression via their
algorithms in via the way they foster
interactions so they encourage for
example peer aggression they encourage
bullying they encouraged mobbing gang
stalking they encourage black humour
they encourage brutal brutal honesty and
so forth
you could say what you've been
encouraged it's an empty space I mean
you can put in this empty space you can
put brutal honesty or you can put
compassion it's not like they are
forcing you it's your choice how to
abuse this empty blank space well of
course it's not
yeah it's not true because the these
platforms have been designed to
condition or as as the founders and
constructors of this platform now our
testing they were conditioned to to
become addictive but it's wrong it's not
addiction never mind we know what
they're trying to say these platforms
encourage repeat use repeat compulsive
use and now we know from psychology that
only these kind of emotions aggression
Envy hatred only these kind of emotions
encourage repeated use in repeated so
there is no way that they have designed
these platforms without being aware that
they must leverage these emotions to
create addiction you're saying that in
all it's a guarantee that there will be
eyeballs on the screen for longer and
more eyeballs on the screen they've
deliberately fostered negative emotions
in that yes anger there was no other way
Envy yes resentment yes and they cannot
come out and say you're wrong
we similarly encourage love because
always psychological studies show that
love does not motivate it does not
create or motivate repeat usage repeat
action repeat does not foster addiction
we have forms of love which are
addictive but then we are talking
stalking arrow to maniac stalking
infatuation
these are pathological States so
pathologies these platforms were
designed with pathology in mind it's not
what I am saying some of the founders of
Facebook and the main engineer of
Facebook in the first few years our now
have now gone public and admitted that
they have built addiction into the
platform and how do you do that the only
way to build addiction into the platform
is to foster engender and enhance
exactly these emotions there is no other
way yes
you can't encourage volunteerism or love
and expect repeat usage simply there's
no studies and support this
Wow Wow okay so what do you think of
this that was about that's heavy
need to play that on all news network I
mean that's heavy if what this
psychologist is really saying is true
yeah it's designed with these negative
emotions intact and that's why you know
people love to get on and comment about
you know how ridiculous you are with
your videos and you know how dare you
have this concept you judger you this
and that right we deal with this all the
time bring on the haters write down the
haters and what I think is hilarious is
the haters they love to comment on like
15 of our videos yeah and you know it's
funny because it's like really hey like
what we said he would keep coming back
and you're the hostile feelings drawing
away I literally would if I thought
somebody was being ridiculous I wouldn't
waste two minutes of my time and I would
just go on and watch something else but
you know the thing that intrigues me is
the fact that love is freedom and that's
what I took away from that is love is
not addictive because it gives a free
choice and it's free that you have to
use something negative to draw people
back because love is not a bondage I
think right right yeah I mean when you
really look at what the Bible says about
love right you just analyze this topic
of love and the Bible says in first
Corinthians 13:4 it says love suffers
long is kind it does not envy it does
not parade itself it is not puffed up
right use the word Envy right it does
not envy and the whole thing that is
literally built around its an Envy
machinae is the opposite of love and it
doesn't foster and encourage us now now
I ought to be very like fair because
some of us in fact there's probably a
lot of people who really do reach out
and say hey man I really like what
you're doing I want to encourage you I
mean I know Mikey
you know reaches out to a lot of other
youtubers and you know he's always
sharing testimony videos with us of you
know hey this guy just came to came to
the Lord and you know he's posting these
kind of things right so there's there
are people who are encouraging we get a
lot of encouragement on our side
and so I don't want to beat up on
everybody saying they know just doesn't
exist out there it really does but as a
whole the whole social media world is
not designed to foster love it's
interesting how that works you can read
a hundred positive comments and that one
negative one will just wipe away all
those oh good point because some Oh
watch an entire hour video of ours and
be like that movie didn't come out
ninety-eight it came out ninety-nine
like that would you pull it away from
the hour-long video waiting an hour to
get there like oh I cannot wait to say
if you're waiting to find holes in it
boy that post will be like this long
right and and this psychologist actually
brought up a really good point do you
know what the enemy of Facebook is
relationships intimacy hmm that is the
enemy of Facebook because all social
media they claim to be a content machine
right Facebook we're giving you content
but who's making the content we are we
are you are actually the employee of
Facebook we are actually the employee of
YouTube without without us there is no
there is no social media site right and
so when you are actually in a loving
state that you are focused and and on
your mate right you're not thumbing
through Facebook and looking at
everybody else's life you're focused on
your mate
so what they do is they get in the
middle of that they discourage us from
these types of relationships pin people
against have all these negative emotions
because that drives us to go back and
pull the lever more and to actually most
more search I would say when you were
talking about how do we respond as
Christians I would say two things one
where are we getting our identity from
if we are having to change like he was
saying everything that the world is
putting out there we're looking at the
wrong horse riding
which is Christ and him crucified there
are new creatures in Christ and our only
identity come no matter where if we are
when if we are in you know incarceration
or we were in a Nazi camp or whatever
our identity has to come from Jesus not
from what's happening and who's
happening around us so I think it just
shows us if I'm so pulled on by this I
am NOT in the intimate place with God
where he's telling me who I am so I'm
bringing that out to the world I'm
trying to draw from the world and the
validation of Who I am but the second
thing I would say is I think one of the
antidotes is really simple I think it is
relationship and I think it's love I
think that a lot of people like you were
saying why are people committing suicide
because of social media because a lot of
people are isolated there they're
already broken they don't know how to
have those they're not about to go to
school and tell other insecure teenagers
am I'm being molested at home or I don't
know what to do to get into this College
I'm afraid of my failure and all that
they don't have those kind of
conversations and so they're dealing
with all this internal battle and then
they're seeking something and they're
looking out on here and this is only
worsening and it's not praying the
intimacy and so they've got nowhere left
to go and so now it's I'm going to take
my life and people gonna cheer while
they watch you know so I think that the
call is still the same that the mandate
Jesus gave it's still relevant in our
time is love one another that is the
answer if you feel loved you don't need
this drug and I just want to say this
one last thing I find this fasting to
this up for myself because I heard about
it I think it was in the 70s
someone did a study on mice and
addiction because his point was the
addiction is not biological it's
emotional and to prove it he did I think
it's called rat part oh yeah and he put
these different mice in different
settings where some of them are isolated
they had access to like a morphine or a
water bottle and the other ones were in
a setting where is a big place with with
wheels and food and other rats and then
there was another one where they spent
part of the time in that and then part
of the time and isolation and the mice
who were isolated all of them were
addicted to the morphine but the ones
who were
integrated into the society they would
taste the morphine then they go back to
the regular because what they were
getting from the social was bad drug
that's beautiful and it just showed and
it makes you want to cry that's
beautiful addiction is just a it's a
love connection we don't know how to
make so now we try to draw it off with
this thing because it's too risky or we
haven't had the experience of love with
another person or Jesus or whatever so
it's not all these you know things we
try to go to the draw a ball for
addiction it's just love it is as simple
as that you're the redemption that we
have so the work it takes to get that
love makes the reward of receiving it
back you know lasting more lasting than
the hate and just getting those quick
releases I'm glad you brought that up
because one of the ways that we can
counterbalance this really is to show
people love this is a dying world out
there and we need to be demonstrating
that connection that we have with Christ
we need to be pouring his love through
us and out to this world I want to share
with you one last video this is there
was mentions a lot of one of the
designers of Facebook and why he left
Facebook he's one of the engineers he
created Facebook with the original team
and he's been very vocal about what to
do with this so I'm gonna kind of share
with you like here's somebody that
designed it made it put it out into the
world and then took a step back and just
went oh my goodness what did we do
listen to this
consumer internet businesses are about
exploiting psychology and that is one
where you want to feel fast because you
know people aren't predictable and so we
want to psychologically figure out how
to manipulate you as fast as possible
and then give you back that dopamine hit
we did that brilliantly at Facebook
Instagram has done it whatsapp has done
it
you know snapchat has done it Twitter
has done it so there are great examples
we chat has doing it there are great
examples of failing fast is the right
path to exploiting psychology of mass
populations of people I want to bring us
back to the point that you were making
about exploiting consumer behavior in a
consumer internet business you said that
this is a time for soul-searching in
social media businesses and and you were
part of building the largest one what
soul-searching are you doing right now
on that I feel tremendous guilt I think
we I think we all knew in the back of
our minds even though we famed this
whole line of like there probably aren't
any really bad unintended consequences I
think in the back deep deep recesses of
our minds we we kind of knew something
bad could happen but I think the way we
defined it was not like this it
literally is a point now where I think
we have created tools that are ripping
apart the social fabric of how society
works that is truly where we are and I
would encourage all of you as the future
leaders of the world to really
internalize how important this is if you
feed the beast that beast will destroy
you if you push back on it we have a
chance to control it and rein it in and
it is a point in time where people need
to hard break from some of these tools
and the things that you rely on the
short term dopamine driven feedback
loops that we have created are
destroying how society works no civil
discourse no cooperation misinformation
miss truth and it's not an American
problem this is not about Russian ads
this is a global problem so we are in a
really bad state of affairs right now in
my opinion it is it is eroding the core
foundations of how people behave by and
between each other and I don't have a
good solution you know my solution is I
just don't use these tools anymore
I haven't for years it's created huge
tension with my friends
huge tensions in my social circles if
you look at like you know my facebook
for you I probably haven't by posted
maybe two times in seven years three
times five times it's like just it's
less than 10 and it's weird I guess I
kind of just innately didn't want to get
programmed and so I just turned tuned it
out but I didn't confront it and now to
see what's happening it's really it
really it really bums me up so think
about this is being one of the creators
and like he said the guilt that he must
feel putting this out into society and
realizing if there has been a huge spike
in suicide if there has been a huge
spike in depression something that you
created or helped to create is
contributing to this yeah that's that's
a heavy weight to carry around I love
that he's taking responsibility for it
and he's open like we don't have a
solution but I myself I've stopped using
this platform that speaks volumes
leading by example Emily totally speaks
volumes and I'll tell you what after
kind of watching this like I was never
really a an avid poster anyway just on
on Facebook at all but you know it's
really made me think about like
intentionally why am i sharing
information why am i what am i posting
what am i putting out there in the world
and it's made me really kind of even
look at the stuff that that we do and
you know I think this this is not
everybody is out there putting things on
that's damaging everybody I mean really
I've I've learned a lot from watching
ministry videos and other people and
seeing testimonies and stuff like that
that's really inspired me so I know
there's positive uses to this
I think he's speaking in a blanket
statement about society as a whole
here's something that it's interesting I
want to leave you guys with it with with
one more little video clip here and then
we'll wrap this up here here's what mr.
Denzel Washington was asked the question
you know in this age of social media
what would you say to young people this
is what he answered turn it off
that's what I would say it's it's hard
for young people now cuz they're going
they're addicted if you don't think
you're addicted and I'm talking about it
anyone from the highest of the lows if
you don't think you're addicted then see
if you can turn it off for a week it got
quiet it didn't get real quiet
it's a tool so we should use it God has
blessed us with free will now if we will
magnified free will on steroids you're
free to go in any direction you want it
will allow you and it's not the enemy
it's just the mat it's it's just a
reflection of our own free will
oh and and we all want to be liked but
now we want to be liked by sixteen
million and we'll now some of us do
anything to be liked we we used to do
anything to be liked but it was the by
the person in front of you now was to be
liked by sixteen million people that you
don't know we have to ask ourselves what
is the long-term if not to the
short-term effect
too much information I think it's some
very valid points he's bringing up sure
it's kind of ironic and interesting
coming from a celebrity you know who has
put himself out there like that but it
sounds like he's you know he's learned
from all this probably he probably was
in the shoes of that person who would do
anything to be liked by 16 million
people and he can speak from experience
yeah interesting coming from him Jesus
was not self-seeking at all even though
he was God literally I mean he could
have roamed around here and and and been
like hey man I created this place but he
didn't and like it says in John 5:30 it
says Jesus himself said I seek not my
own will but the will of the Father
which had sent me jesus was was
demonstrating to us what a real life
should look like not being self-absorbed
not being self seeking and I think
that's the true path to happiness Luke
9:23 says if any man come after me let
him deny himself and take up his cross
daily and follow me I think it's
interesting how the devil always has a
counterfeit for what God is doing right
follow me follow me on twitter follow
this follow that follow over here with
this organization or this organization
right when really we should be following
Jesus that's really what we should be
doing Jesus wasn't self-seeking at all
in fact when he was in the Garden of
Gethsemane he says a very very
interesting prayer not as I will Lord
because remember he's sitting there
begging God if it was possible take this
cup from me is there another way is
there some way his humanity was was
flashing through at this moment of him
literally saying I don't want to go
through with this his human side saying
it but he says not as I will as you will
go on as thy will be done now I bring
that up because if anyone watching out
there is experiencing addiction doesn't
know what to do right here is the key to
being able to deal with any addiction
not just social media it could be drugs
sex pornography you name it
here is the key I don't know how to fix
this but Christ
you do god you do not as I will as you
will I give you permission God to change
my heart and let God work on us from the
inside out
does that make sense no sir the more
that we put the blinders on the more
that we try to just put all those
controls on and we are not literally
turning the wheel over to Jesus and
saying help me through this process I
give you the option to to be able to
change my tastes my desires my
addictions give that over to Christ that
would be a true and tried way of being
able to deal with addiction I think when
you look at the story of the woman at
the well
and Jesus said bring your husband and
she said I don't have one and he said
you're right you've had five he didn't
say now go home and tell all those men
get by and come back here he gave her
what she was really needing and I think
that we tried to put the cart before the
horse we try to get rid of the problem
when the problem is there because
there's a deficit we don't even need to
get rid of the problem when you to take
in the thing that we're really needing
and it'll push the process right now
that's right good point well thank you
guys for watching this led live we hope
that you aren't completely walking away
from this fearful but you probably need
to get rid of your phones and delete all
your accounts right now just kidding
just actually don't delete our YouTube
channel you know if you like this video
please share it with other people this
is a very real situation and we wanted
to do something that was very real with
with you know these struggles that we
all experienced so please by all means
you know pray about this one
think about it share it with your kids
talk about it with your family members
and of course we want to hear your
comments if they're only good comments
not negative ones I like to hear from
those haters send all of them to Mikey
if you're any good
yeah and he will respond to every one
that's right thank you guys for watching
and we'll catch you next week
[Music]